j'ai dressé les clowns des acrobates les
gens du voyage ah ah ça me rappelle des
souvenirs que je voudrais avoir aidé
amour que je n'ai pas connu à tant rêver
j'ai gâché mes vins berges la gamberge
la gamberge un très chouette le gars qui
chantait ça l'autre soir au cabaret mais
mais ma parole c'est lui comment
s'appelle-t-il chan yan ces gens
viennent et lui prend décidément il n'y
a qu'à demander pour être servi
pour en revenir à ce que je disais avant
les vacances je voudrais vous chanter
une chanson qui remonte aux sources
c'est à dire une chanson inspirée par le
folklore le folklore est une des bases
fondamentales de la chanson humanitaire
et sociale et je trouve bien triste
qu'ils ne soient pas mieux considérer
qu'il n'est en effet le folklore est
généralement bien considérer mais
uniquement dans son pays d'origine ce
qui fait que si l'on prend pour exemple
une chanson anglaise comme le god save
the king
on constate que c'est une chanson qui a
un énorme succès en angleterre mais qui
en france n'a presque pas de succès du
tout sauf de temps en temps à l'occasion
de certaines réunions sportives et
encore faut-il que ce jour-là il y ait
des anglais sur le terrain je trouve ça
infiniment dommage et c'est pour
redonner ses lettres de noblesse au
folklore que j'ai voulu m'inspirer des
thèmes folkloriques du gabon pour écrire
une chanson en contre point que j'ai
dédié au docteur chouette there et que
j'ai intitulé le mambo du légionnaire
m
ce pianiste et matignon a fort à aller
cheminée dignement vont jouer pour
oublier cette tournée le cattani
longtemps
danseuse exceptionnellement belle avec
th sensationnel mantel ont été sous le
thème hague a dansé dansé ou c'est la
cata simon hughes blessure une une qui
collait le sable car à quoi l'oeil sur
lignes allaient rouler sur les paliers
qui pend chez leur tronc qui ce décès
celle ci romo sauf un chef zen des
ricochets 1 quand le vent soufflait qui
l'attend feront souffler l'on n'avait
pas de roeulx lez les sources se
camoufler le désert c'est un des sous le
bruit grächen beaucoup des coups de
tonnerre qui gronde des camps les c'est
clair descendez le soleil dardait ses
rayons sur les doigts des moustiques
cavalcade f comme des farfadets des
chameliers qui paraissaient les cheveux
se hérissaient écart de vente s'adresse
à des mirages et qui plus est ceux qui
voudraient que lorsque l'on ne pouvait
plus marcher si l'on a fait mal aux
pieds on en crever car le sable faisait
des tombes à ceux qui décèdent des dans
ce curieux bled où dès le matin
entendait
mambo jura piano système à tignes mans
phone
un légionnaire est né à tignes mambo de
hou échoué pour oublier cette ou rang le
cat 1 qui l'attend il a dans ce secteur
yann et le mans bel effet que d en chine
ans à sillonner le mans telle qu'on
aurait dit
un souffle aux tags à danser danser sous
le ciel du sahara gags désopilants ou
sarasar samatan que les mousses mais les
légionnaires au sahara sarah sarah
pourront faire des fugues et et toc